good morning everybody seven o'clock two
big questions this morning will the
british iranian mother nazigary
ratcliffe be coming home very soon and
what is president putin's next move in
ukraine with some military intelligence
suggesting russia is struggling to
conduct its offensive in some parts in
the face of ukrainian resistance the
foreign secretary liz trusts on the
programme very shortly we'll also talk
to nazanin's mp tulips dig who says
she's been given her british passport
back it's wednesday the 16th of march
what next for nazanin who's being held
in iran after the prime minister says
conversations are still going on the
foreign secretary with us very shortly
indeed
explosions in kiev this morning and
reports 400 people inside a hospital in
mariopol are being held there
nato defense ministers meet in brussels
this morning as the ukrainian president
offers a potential olive branch to
russia about his country not joining
nato
trying to wean the west off russian oil
the prime minister arrives in the gulf
for a visit that's been severely
criticized after saudi arabia executed
81 people in a single day
heroes on the front line will speak to
the doctors who are caring for children
in the besieged city of kharkiv
a traumatic search police apologize
after a report finds racism was likely
to have been a factor in a young girl
being strip searched on her own
also on the program for you this morning
we're going to be speaking to the
british academic who was imprisoned in
the uae but released in 2018 to hear his
story
and the dance for ukraine will speak to
a ukrainian ballet dancer about the gala
taking place in london this weekend to
raise funds for those impacted by the
war
[Music]
morning everyone the thing you all want
to know this morning is is nazanin
coming home the woman who will know more
than anybody else is the foreign
secretary she's with us good morning
thank you for joining good morning kate
is she coming home
well we are working very hard and i've
made a priority as foreign secretary to
secure the release of nazanin anushay
and murad who are all detained in iran
we've also made it
a priority to
pay the debt that we owe to iran
but i can't say anything more than that
i'm afraid tell us about the debt 400
million quid there abouts as a result of
tanks that were paid for but then never
delivered where are we with that
well we have been clear this is a
legitimate debt that we do
oh iran and we have been seeking ways to
pay it how can we pay it if they're a
sanction and they can they can't get the
money
well i can't go into details i'm afraid
but we are looking for ways to pay it
and we have been very clear
it is a legitimate debt that the united
kingdom owes iran
could it be through as has been
suggested by a previous foreign
secretary through
medical equipment and medicines and the
like
well as i've said we're looking at ways
of
paying that debt
that is a separate issue from the issue
of the detainees it was one of the first
things i did as foreign secretary was
met the iranian foreign minister to urge
him to release the unfairly d
the unfairly detained british people
namely nazanin
murad and anushay we continue to work
round the clock to achieve that come
back to that in a second if i could just
seek further clarification as far as the
debt is concerned has that actually been
paid in one way or another at the moment
as we speak this morning
i i can't say anything more about that
uh at this moment okay what can you tell
us about where the three uh dual
nationals are right now
i'm afraid kay i also can't say anything
about that
at this stage okay what i can tell you
is that we are working extremely hard to
secure the release of the detainees we
have been working very hard to do that
over the past few months we are in
discussions as the prime minister has
made clear but i can't say anything else
at this stage i'm very very sorry no no
not to be able to say anything else and
i know how desperately
the families want to see
their loved ones back but i really can't
say anything else at this point of
course and we're just asking questions
that everybody at home will be asking
this morning everybody very excited
about the prospect of these three jewel
nationals wiley being able to come home
have has the dial moved at all for over
the last few days
as i say we have been having discussions
i met my counterpart the iranian foreign
minister back in september
we've been in regular touch since uh we
do have a team in tehran but i
absolutely can't say anything else at
this stage do you know when you might be
able to say more
no i don't okay um let's move on then
but i mean obviously we are incredibly
hopeful that it looks as though the tone
has changed somewhat as far as dealing
with iran is concerned and there have
been lots of times when her husband has
been desperate and um her young daughter
has now of course come to live in the uk
so they are hoping against hope that she
and the other two
it's a desperate situation and um
you know my hearts are with the families
who have suffered so greatly and of
course with nazanin and nishi and of
course murad as well yeah okay um so
obviously you'll update us as soon as
you know more but at this stage you
can't tell we know that she got her
passport back yesterday obviously that's
what her mp tweeted but that that's
moving in the right direction isn't it i
can't say any more i'm afraid okay
okay the team in toronto obviously um is
is an interesting move as well and
you've been on my program before and
said that it is a legitimate debt that
does need to be paid so you know we'll
take what we can from that um as far as
ukraine is concerned we also heard that
um
three british nationals were killed in
the explosion near the poland border
over the weekend do we know any more
about that
we don't have any more information about
that what we know is that vladimir
putin's plans are not going according to
plan he's not making the progress
expected and we know the sanctions that
we've put on are working they're having
a debilitating effect on the russian
economy yesterday we announced 370 more
designations of individuals and
oligarchs we've now designated over a
thousand individuals and entities more
than either the us or the eu so we are
really putting the pressure on
everything from banks
to the oil and gas industry to the
luxury goods industry and to individuals
in russia and those sanctions are really
beginning to bite and we're working very
very closely with our allies to do this
because putin
only understands strength
and he will only
understand when we successfully
stop the funding into the russian war
machine by debilitating the russian
economy but also we're helping the
ukrainians with their struggle by
providing the defensive weapons uh my
colleague defense secretary has supplied
end laws into ukraine we're working with
other allies to do that we just need to
step up these efforts because what we
can see is that his offensive isn't
working it's of course having a
horrendous and devastating effect on the
ukrainian people we're doing all we can
to support with humanitarian aid but
what we need to do now is step up that
pressure on putin to secure the
withdrawal from ukraine and to end this
appalling war
will there be more sanctions to come
there will be more sanctions to come
as i've said we've already sanctioned
over a thousand individuals and entities
we've sanctioned 10
major banks along with the united states
the eu of sanctioned three banks we'd
like to see them sanction even more
banks
we want to see a full swift freeze uh
currently we've frozen swift for a
number of banks but not all of them and
we want to see a complete
elimination of dependency on russian oil
and gas the uk of
you we have said that by the end of this
year we will stop all gas all oil
imports from russia many european
countries are very dependent on oil and
gas we want to help them reduce
oil and gas dependency say that russia
has nowhere to fund
this appalling war machine
what would more sanctions look like
well more sanctions on individuals we've
got more individuals on our list
more companies
and more sanctions collectively with our
allies
on
the oil and gas industry as well as
encouraging more countries to put
sanctions on so 141 countries voted
against russia at the un general
assembly we want to see them follow suit
we've seen countries like south korea
and japan put sanctions on but we'd like
to see all 141 put sanctions on russia
so they're completely isolated in the
international community how do we stop
these oligarchs running away though like
abramovic seems to have done okay we've
got some of um
his some would say ill-gotten gains
staying here in the uk but you know
managed to flee the country pretty
quickly
this is why it's so important to work
with our allies across the g7 and beyond
so this simply is nowhere for these
oligarchs to hide there is nowhere it is
legitimate for them to live their
lifestyles uh have their yachts or have
their planes and that's why we've had a
total ban
on russian planes into the united
kingdom uh we've also done the same for
vessels and we're encouraging all of our
allies to do that and we're working with
our g7 partners on the task force on
targeting these assets under what
circumstances would abramovich be
welcomed back to the uk
well we we have put these sanctions on
because of the appalling war that putin
has unleashed and the first thing we
need to see putin do is withdraw his
troops uh from ukraine and then we need
to see an end to the threats to ukraine
we need a
positive settlement for ukraine that
guarantees
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity and
who knows what might happen after that
clearly uh ukraine has already been
devastated you know we've seen the
appalling scenes in the cities across
ukraine and there will need to be
discussions about how
how those um
how the rebuilding is paid for
i'm not going to speculate on exactly
uh what will happen in the future but we
need to see those who contributed to
this appalling war suffer the
consequences as of as i'm afraid to say
uh the people of ukraine have suffered
the consequences so just go back
abramovic would be welcome back into the
uk once the war in ukraine has ended i
haven't said that no i'm asking i
haven't no i haven't i haven't said that
because i'm saying that even if the war
was to end and i fear we are not near
the end
at this stage you know huge devastation
has been caused lives have been lost as
a result of this war and there will need
to be a reckoning
with all the people who supported putin
including abramovich and the like
including ibrahimovic and the oligarch
cash etc that has been seized that you
think could potentially be used to pay
for uh the rebuilding of ukraine we're
not ruling anything out at this stage
as far as ukraine um and and the
president is concerned he spoke of
course to parliament didn't he at uh i
think it was the end of last week he was
very well received when he did that um
what more support can we offer the
people of ukraine at the moment of
course we're you know the great british
public are opening their doors and their
homes to those that that can arrive and
a hundred thousand people have offered
their properties um a room in their
properties so far but what else can the
british at the british government do to
support the ukrainian people well the
two things the ukrainian government want
most is us to put more sanctions on
russia
and for us to support with more
defensive weapons into ukraine and we
are stepping up on both of those we're
now leading in terms of the number of
sanctions we put we've put on
russian oligarchs and individuals but
we're also
way ahead in terms of our sanctions on
banks we want to encourage people to do
more and we also want to reduce european
dependence on oil and gas and the second
thing they want is defensive weapons and
we've supplied end laws uh we're now
looking at the star streak uh air
defense missiles
the third thing we we are doing is
supplying humanitarian aid we're the
second biggest humanitarian donor uh to
ukraine uh after the united states we're
supplying electricity generators we're
flying children out for uh hospital
treatment in the united kingdom uh we're
supplying
food we're supplying uh medicines
and we we continue to do that working
with the neighboring countries
particularly poland uh who are facing of
course a major a major flee of
refugees into poland so we are we are
working really hard at the front line
it's obviously difficult
to get into some of those besieged
cities we're working with the
international agencies
who are doing that but we're doing all
we can to supply the humanitarian age
and british people have been incredibly
generous
the deck appeals already raised 130
million
uh which is way ahead of i think many
other appeals well most out of time but
i just want to ask you about saudi
arabia which of course is where the
prime minister is at the moment as a
woman you know i find it very difficult
to comprehend the way that women are
treated in a country like saudi you have
to do business with them how do you go
about that do you have to hold your nose
i do not agree with
all of the policies of the saudi
government of course i do
do not but the reality is
that we are facing
an aggressor in vladimir putin who is
wantonly destroying a neighboring
sovereign nation and we do need to work
with countries across the world to find
alternative sources of oil and gas and
russia is a threat not just to regional
security but to global security
so we
we have to work with all of
our allies around the world including
saudi arabia to find alternative sources
saudi arabia is not a global security
threat in the way that russia is and we
have to work with them we have to work
terrible
the policies of saudi arabia what i'm
saying is we are in a
existential threat about european
security and global security and we need
to find alternative sources of oil and
gas so we are no longer dependent on
vladimir putin and his appalling regime
i have to let you go um
be great to talk to you for longer but
we must leave it there thank you very
much hopefully next time you come we'll
be celebrating the fact that three uh
dual nationals are back home thank you
very much thanks a lot
uh the telegraph let's have a look what
they're doing they're flashing with
ukraine we'll never join nato following
president zielenski's statement
yesterday
and the guardian also looks at this
story as president zielinski
acknowledges that ukraine will not
become a member of nato
the times also leads with those comments
and the front page of the daily mirror
this morning examining boris johnson's
trip to saudi arabia to to talk oil and
also energy supplies
ukraine's president has said that there
is definitely room for compromise in
peace talks with russia suggesting that
ukraine could drop its ambition to join
nato but he also had an uncompromising
message telling moscow in his nightly
address that the war would end in
disgrace poverty and year-long isolation
for russians let's take you through the
key development should we talks between
ukraine and russia will resume this
morning with president zielenski
describing the negotiations as more
realistic he comes after the ukrainian
leader admitted there's no chance his
country will join nato
according to the latest intelligence
update from the uk's ministry of defence
russia is struggling to conduct
offensive operations in the face of
sustained ukrainian resistance
a 36-hour curfew has begun in the
capital of kiev after residential
buildings were hit by heavy shelling
which killed five people yesterday
explosions were heard this morning
local authorities say that around two
thousand cars were able to leave the
besieged city of mariopol where russian
forces are reported to have taken 400
patients and medical staff at a hospital
as hostages
here's greg here's greg marlon
this used to be a quiet
neighborhood in the city center
and now it is
completely in ruins with every home
destroyed lives are being shattered in
ukraine not military targets but
civilian ones dozens of strikes in the
past 24 hours in this the second largest
city kharkiv this country is being taken
apart piece by piece by russian forces
standing in their way ukraine's military
continues to defy the odds these some of
the soldiers injured in pushing the
russians back from the city of mikolayev
we started to attack the enemy and came
under fire
our tank the turret to be exact stopped
working
the others left without warning then the
russian tanks came and we barely managed
to get away
there was defiance too in ukraine's
parliament three quarters of its members
attending in person an emergency session
and how about this for a show of
solidarity from europe the polish czech
and slovenian prime ministers traveling
to kiev a city under curfew for talks
with president zielenski
in his latest address to the ukrainian
people he offered the slightest bit of
hope
everyone should work including our
representatives our delegation for
negotiations with the russian federation
it is difficult but important as any war
ends with an agreement the meetings
continue
and i am informed the positions during
the negotiations already sound more
realistic
he'll bring his virtual tour of the
world's capitals to washington today to
ask the us congress for more help
the humanitarian aid is arriving in
ukraine this shipment in the city of
venezia vital supplies for those who've
remained behind and who've seen the
places they call home reduced to this
this footage filmed by the ukrainian
military in the city of okturka another
left in ruins and for all its defiance a
country wondering where all this ends
greg milam sky news washington
well the russian journalist who
interrupted a state tv news broadcast by
holding up a sign protesting against the
country's invasion of ukraine has been
fined the equivalent of 210 pounds it's
now illegal in russia
to contradict the government's narrative
of the war and the kremlin claimed that
marina ozviakakova's actions amounted to
an act of hooliganism it's not clear if
she'll face more serious charges over
the protest she spoke yesterday as she
came out of court
i made this decision by myself because i
don't like
russia starts this
invasion and
it was really terrible
is watching events in ukraine even more
closely than the rest of us following
russia's invasion of ukraine
taiwan is holding various military
exercises in the coming weeks in case
china were to take the region by force
uh let's find out more should we tom
standing by for us now hi tom tell us
more
morning
taiwan describes these as routine
military drills it does have to be in a
state of preparedness because it does
face this existential threat but it has
raised its alert level as a result of
the ukraine war and there are
similarities between
uk and ukraine and russia and taiwan and
china these are young small democracies
next doors to authoritarian military
giants who have designs on that
territory so the question has come up
but both sides would actually try and
heighten the differences too taiwan
would say its economy is a lot bigger
it's a lot further away uh it's a lot
harder to take and the question of
whether the us intervene still hasn't
been settled china for its part it has
been talking about taiwan throughout
this crisis and it doesn't like the
comparison because it insists that
taiwan is part of its territory this is
not about invading a sovereign country
because it doesn't see taiwan as a
sovereign country it sees it as an
internal affair so this has always been
these tensions but the ukraine crisis
the ukraine war has put them into fresh
perspective and both sides really will
be looking at the lessons learned i
think china will see that the us has not
intervened in ukraine and wonder if that
would be the case for taiwan taiwan for
its part would have seen how a smaller
army against a vastly stronger military
has managed to hold them out as managed
to fight them back in many instances and
wonder whether those lessons can be
applied to its own defense now this
isn't an imminent danger there is not an
invasion about to happen we would see
that building up as we did with ukraine
and war is not inevitable but this is a
priority for the chinese communist party
and it's a priority for xi jinping it's
one of the things that could cement his
legacies up there with chairman mao and
dong xiaoping in terms of the pantheon
of communist leaders we're not there yet
but i think both sides looking at
ukraine uh very nervously and trying to
draw lessons from what's happening and
that's why you're seeing these drills on
those taiwanese islands today
okay thanks tom thank you
still to come on the programme for you
this morning uh we'll get the very
latest on nasa and zagari ratcliffe
situation going to be speaking to her mp
labour's tulip sadiq just after eight
o'clock
also speaking the former international
trade secretary dr liam fox about the
prime minister's visit to the gulf as he
tries to reduce reliance on our moscow
for oil and gas
and we'll be speaking to two doctors out
of ukraine's second biggest city kharkiv
as they continue providing palliative
care for children in the war-torn region
[Music]
chatting to the foreign secretary a few
moments ago i'm sure you caught that the
prime minister is presently uh in the
middle east trying to secure an oil deal
he's just said this from abu dhabi
if you look at what putin's doing in
ukraine it's it's causing global
uncertainty and
a spike in the price of of oil that
feeds through to the four courts in in
the uk everybody can see the effect of
the increase in uh in gas prices uh
that's coming through and we've got to
make sure that we're uh we're prepared
and we're taking steps to to mitigate
that uh to help people with the cost of
living so next week we're gonna be
sending out the the energy strategy for
for the uk massive uh jump forward on on
renewables
more nuclear using our own hydrocarbons
more effectively also looking at what we
can do to source hydrocarbons from
places other than russia we've got to
get off russian hydrocarbons but the
reason for coming here
is that it's not just that they've got
oil they're also some of the biggest
investors here in the in the gulf in uk
renewables in our wind farms and uh and
that's what we'll be talking about do
you think you can persuade oil producers
today to turn the taps on
it's not just a question of uh looking
at uh the opec countries and what they
can do to uh to increase supply there's
also as i say though that is important
uh there's also the issue of uh emirati
investment in uk wind farms already huge
uh what more can they do uh we need to
we need to double the the pace of our of
our construction of wind farms we're
already the one of the biggest producers
of offshore wind power in the world when
we look at the the the dependency that
the west in particular has built up on
putin's hydrocarbons on putin's oil and
gas we can see what a mistake that was
because he's been able to blackmail the
west to hold western economies to ransom
we need independence part of your answer
to that is to work with a regime like
saudi arabia i mean why are you
comfortable working with a regime like
that has a very questionable human
rights record and you've been criticized
by many people for being willing to
appeal to them and i've raised all those
issues many many times over the past
since i was foreign secretary and beyond
and i'll raise them all again
today
but we have to we have long long
standing relationships with this part of
the world and we need to recognize the
the very important uh relationship that
we have and the strength of of that
relationship
not just in in hydrocarbons this is
about investment in the in the uk over
the long term and
genuinely you should look at some of the
things i mean you talk about saudi
arabia
they're announcing today a one billion
pound investment in uh in t-side in
aviation fuel in green aviation fuel i
should say and that is the kind of thing
that we want to encourage doesn't in any
way mean uh that we can't stick to our
principles and erase those issues that
uh we all care about briefly on
president silency he appears to have
signaled that he
doesn't expect now to join nato and he
sounds slightly more optimistic about
peace talks what's your take on what's
happening how things are developing i
talked to vladimir
again uh yesterday and
you know of course i understand what
he's saying about
nato and the reality of the position and
everybody's always said and we made it
clear to to putin there's no way ukraine
is going to join nato anytime soon but
the the decision about the future of
ukraine
has got to be
for the ukrainian people and for uh for
vladimir zelinsky as
as their elected leader and we will back
him and the most important thing
is that putin's aggression uh his
absolutely barbaric attacks on uh on
ukraine should stop
and they should not be seen to have
succeeded and they won't succeed and
just lastly there's been some renewed
optimism about nasa against gary
radcliffe i know you were asked about
this yesterday but now you're in the
region can you update people on any
progress is it true that there's a
negotiating team in tehran
it's true and has been for a long time
laura that we're negotiating for the
release of our our dual nationals in in
tehran some very sad cases
including nazanin i really don't think i
should say much more i'm sorry
although you know things are are moving
forward i shouldn't really say much
more right now just because those
negotiations continue to be underway and
we're we're going right up to the wire
tamara's here uh foreign secretary
echoing that as well of course and and
and agreeing that there was a team in
tehran trying to get them home yes he
said things are moving forward but we
have to be very careful because of
course there's been false dawns before
for paul uh nazanin zagari radcliffe and
her family and of course the families of
the other two jewel nationals who were
there as well
boris johnson was careful to say that
they've been negotiating for some time
it looks like things may be reaching a
crunch point but of course we can never
be sure until
you know probably anyone is actually on
a plane that anything is going to start
moving there but tentative hope after it
was revealed by her mp yesterday that
nazneen had got her passport back
yesterday so of course fingers crossed
for all of them the foreign secretary
did stress that this is unrelated in the
british government's eyes to the payment
of 400 million pounds that the
government accepts it needs to pay for a
tank deal back in 1979 the iranians paid
the british government never handed over
the tanks because of course the uh the
shah of iran was deposed so that may be
paid will that unlock some movement on
the cases of the dual nationals okay
let's hear what liz trust had to say
we are working very hard and i've made a
priority as foreign secretary to secure
the release of nazanin anushay and murad
who are all detained in iran
we've also made it
a priority to
pay the debt that we owe to iran
but i can't say anything more than that
i'm afraid tell us about the debt 400
million quid there abouts as a result of
um tanks that were paid for but they're
never delivered where are we with that
well we have been clear this is a
legitimate debt that we do
oh iran and we have been seeking ways to
pay it how can we pay it if they're a
sanction and they
they can't get the money
well i can't go into details i'm afraid
but we are looking for ways to pay it
and we have been very clear it is a
legitimate debt that the united kingdom
owes iran everybody very excited about
the prospect of these three dual
nationals finally being able to come
home have has the dial moved at all for
over the last few days
as i say we have been having discussions
i met my counterpart the uranium foreign
minister back in september
we've been in regular touch since uh we
do have a team in tehran but i
absolutely can't say anything else at
this stage do you know when you might be
able to say more
uh no i don't
what do you make of that
well it sounds like she's being very
careful which she must be at this stage
but some of the issues which have been
discussed in relation to this the
payment of the debt which the uk
government stresses is unrelated but now
the government says it is legitimate and
wants to pay it how it can pay it given
that iran is subject to uk sanctions and
has been since the collapse of the
nuclear deal back in 2018 that has been
one of the stumbling blocks to paying
that debt um is there a way possibly
forward with that with the negotiations
in vienna over a new nuclear deal or can
it be paid in some other way that isn't
cash all of these issues um have been
bubbling away for many months now if we
are close to a resolution of all those
things and nazanin zagari reckless
lawyer suggested that may be the case
then perhaps that may unlock the key to
her release certainly her husband
richard has linked the two issues and
said that in the minds of the iranian
regime they are all linked exactly so um
we don't know when we might hear more we
did hear from tulip sadiq yesterday she
tweeted yesterday from her on the
program later on what did she say
um she said yesterday that
nazanin zagari radcliffe had had her
passport returned to her she is in
tehran
under under house arrest and it had been
returned to her and so she was hopeful
that something may be moving she said
that there was a british negotiating
team there but of course
we need to be very careful because these
negotiations may well be at a delicate
stage which is why the prime minister
said we are working very hard on it we
have been negotiating for some time but
of course he knows that
nazanin has had
false hope before and um that of course
her family won't be feeling
reassured until she is on her way back
to the uk if indeed that is what is
going to happen um thanks very much
tomorrow's take out nine o'clock looking
forward to it thanks very much indeed
let's bring in dr liam fox should we who
knows very well about negotiating in
that region of the world hello to dr fox
thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning obviously um you
can appreciate why the foreign secretary
and the prime minister are both being
very cautious is there anything that we
can pick from what they've said do you
think
well in terms of uh the negotiations
with iran
um i've never been in favor of the jcpoa
so i'm probably the wrong person uh to
ask on that but clearly it's a very
complex situation and
they're being i think understandably
very
cautious about what they say
yeah the prime minister is presently um
in the region as i said to try to
negotiate a deal
with the saudis in regards to oil how
tricky is that to do
well it's it's essential that the prime
minister makes this visit because uh
energy security and economic security
and national security have become
increasingly interlinked in recent years
um and it's essential that we understand
our energy balance in the united kingdom
although we've got much better at
producing green electricity from
renewables electricity still only makes
up about 19 of our energy consumption
still about 44
is accounted for by oil mainly for
transport and the transport industry in
the uk and about 30
uh or so for gas for for heating so
we're still quite a long way from being
non-fossil fuel dependent and i think
that we need to recognize that for as
long as we are dependent on fossil fuels
we need to have a wider range uh where
they come from
preferably producing more ourselves of
course um but when we get to that
international dependence we have to make
sure that more of it's going to come
from a predictable source and not as
we've seen in recent years becoming more
dependent on russian oil and gas the uk
of course is not particularly dependent
on that directly but we are indirectly
because uh our major trading partners
including the european union are very
dependent for example on russian gas
but our saudis really the right sort of
people for us to do business with i mean
we were wooed by president putin um 20
years ago
and of late he's been murdering babies
and pregnant women the saudis killed 81
people in a single day are those the
sort of people we want to do business
with
i think you have to draw a big
difference between an invasion of
ukraine and something that's done
through a country's judicial system
whatever i i think of the death penalty
the um i think there's a there's a real
issue here um saudi arabia has actually
been a very good ally of the united
kingdom in
security uh and intelligence
areas where the prime minister's
obviously also been inside the uae which
is a great ally also uh of the united
kingdom
we've got a real issue not with not with
uk dependency on russian oil and gas
although more on oil and gas but the
huge dependence of our european partners
that's got to therefore be an
international effort
to try to deal with this there's no
point in britain alone dealing with its
energy dependence issues
when our european trading partners
and in many cases industrial partners
through supply chains have this russian
dependence and we create it's very clear
that
in putin's
kremlin uh we have uh an aggressive
uh
entity that doesn't care for the death
or destruction is raining down on
ukraine at the present time and we can't
possibly be in hawk it's really why i
think it's very welcome that the new
german chancellor chancellor schultz has
stopped the certification of nordstrom 2
which would actually have made germany
more dependent on on russian gas itself
so there are some positive moves within
that but clearly we've got to act as an
international community to ensure that
we can continue with our industrial
activity on our route to decarbonization
yeah i'm going to have to push back on
that i'm afraid dr fox and point to the
fact that back in 2018 uh a saudi-led
coalition um
air strike killed 26 kids on a school
bus as they were going to school um in
the yemen as you know so you know
it's not just what their policy is on
the death penalty it's them
doing airstrikes in foreign countries
dude i have to push back again on that
and that the um that saudi arabia was
responding to attacks on saudi arabia
including missile strikes uh on uh
okay to bomb a school bus no it's
absolutely not and the international
community uh
condemned that and
but this is a
a war in yemen that was launched against
saudi arabia by the iranian-backed
houthis we seem to forget that and it's
also very strange that when we're
talking about human rights no one seems
to be criticizing uh iran's very high
numbers of executions or the fact that
they have been backing terrorist
organizations in i think
in both saudi arabia and elsewhere so i
think you've got to try to get these
things in proportion and see the wider
perspective
i think we're the first to uh criticize
iran as well as and when is necessary
let's talk about ukraine while we're on
the subject should we it looks as though
um
that putin seems to be moving to plan c
given that a and b don't seem to have
worked so far um what more can the
british do to help
the ukrainian government
well i think that what we're seeing is
real pressure now uh appearing on the
russian government it was always very
clear that financial sanctions
particularly the sanctioning of the
russian central bank would do a great
deal of damage to putin's authority and
ability to run his economy and some of
the other measures for example banning
dual use
items with damage
his war machine too
i think it's becoming increasingly clear
that uh his logistics his military
capabilities are not what they thought
they were the russians have suffered far
more damage than they thought they would
the fact they're using conscripts and
looking for troops elsewhere i think
tends to raise questions about whether
the russian military are actually
genuinely committed to this or whether
there are splits in policy there
whatever whatever the reason you're
quite right putin
has not achieved his objectives the
ukrainians have been much better and we
should continue to supply them with the
military equipment that they're asking
for
and i think that it's it's
more than anything else it's a moral
duty to help people defend themselves
and of course it's their right under the
u.n charter as a sovereign nation to do
so and i think that we have to recognize
that this is not just an attack on
ukraine it's a an attack on all the
values we have of international law
of sovereignty and of free people making
the decisions to defend themselves in a
democracy
good to talk to you dr fox as always
thanks for taking the time
uh nato defense ministers meeting in
brussels this morning with military
commanders instructed to draw up plans
for a new way to deter russia let's find
out more should we and laura who's been
covering the story for us all week is
with us again hi laura good morning good
morning um what are we expecting
yeah morning k well ben wallace defense
secretary has just arrived here he
stressed the importance of the alliance
he talked about the privilege of being a
member of nato and then said it was
important nato now looks further ways to
show support to ukraine and support for
ukrainian freedoms as well so
discussions will be centering around
that ben wallister tweeted already
saying that the uk is planning to
provide ukraine with anti-air weapons as
well so we talk around what they can do
yesterday we heard very uh sort of stern
words from secretary general jen
stoltenberg talking about this new
reality as he put it the need to reset
our military posture and so what they'll
be doing here is looking at ways they
can engage military commanders to come
up with strategies and things to bolster
that eastern flank now they're already
40 000 nato-led troops
pretty much centered around those
countries bordering ukraine at the
moment looking at ways to reinforce that
potentially and also looking at ways to
strengthen air defense systems as well
in recent days there have been it's
thought three
russian drone incursions into nato
countries poland um
croatia and and romania as well and the
worry is nato isn't really commenting
much about that at the moment but the
worry is these sorts of incidents could
lead to accidents and that could
inadvertently see things really spiral
out of control so very much a need to
tread carefully when it comes to this
but as i say a strengthening of
positions along the along the uh in nato
eastern alliance countries particularly
and then talks to ben wallace confirmed
about this polish proposal to put an
international peacekeeping mission in
ukraine as well that will be on the
agenda as well and appearing via video
link for the first of the meetings kay
will be the ukrainian defense minister
as well and he will no doubt ask for
more military support in ukraine
okay thank you thanks a lot
let's tell you about a secondary school
girl who was strip searched alone in
2020
by the met after two female officers
falsely suspected her of using cannabis
a safeguarding report into the incident
which happened in hackney says it was
unjustified and racism was likely to
have been a fact melania has more for us
in the newsroom for us now hello to you
melania good morning um what happened to
this young girl
good morning kay well teachers actually
suspected that she had cannabis on her
because they thought she smelled of it
they called the police two female
officers as you said stripped searched
her no other adults were present and the
safeguarding review says that even
though they knew she was on her period
she was forced to remove her sanitary
towel now no no cannabis was found and
the girls were sent home in a taxi
however the impact on her has been
profound her family says that she went
from a happy-go-lucky girl to someone
who's a recluse hardly speaks and
self-harms they strongly believe that
racism played a part in what happened to
her and this safeguarding review agrees
saying that it would have been unlikely
that she would have had the same
experience had she not been black the
report also says that something called
adultification also likely paid apart
and that means when adults perceive
black children as older than they are
because they seem to them more
streetwise now this incident is being
investigated by the independent office
for police conduct it was condemned by
the london mayor sadiq khan he said this
is shocking and deeply disturbing i'm
extremely concerned by the findings of
this report no child should ever have to
face a situation like this it's entirely
right that the incident is being
investigated by the iopc scotland yard
has now apologized for the incident and
they say it should have never happened
thank
you now the leader of hong kong carrie
lam has said there are no plans to
further tighten covert 19 rules as the
city battles to contain an escalating
outbreak
hong kong health authorities reported 27
765 new coveted 19 cases on tuesday and
228 deaths making it the worst outbreak
to date the upcoming election currently
set for may could also be delayed as a
result looking at the latest covert data
here and in the most recent 24-hour
period the uk has registered 109
800 new cases 200 new deaths taking the
total death toll to 163.95
thousands of race goes descended on a
gloucestershire racecourse yesterday for
the first day of the cheltenham races of
course crowds returned to the track this
year after organizers were forced to
hold 2021's event behind closed doors
frankie de torre pictured here in the
mail this morning having a a blast with
uh penny lancaster
good for him
um now some users are reporting
difficulty in ordering lateral flow
tests for home delivery from the
official government website the free
availability of these tests is scheduled
to end on the 1st of april but it comes
as nearly 110 000 people have tested
positive across the uk in the latest
24-hour period i've been trying for the
last four days
nothing
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you now and fire engines
have reportedly attended pinewood
studios after a fire broke out on a film
set buckingham buckinghamshire fire and
rescue have said uh superman harry
potter and the james bond movies are
among the blockbusters that have been
filmed there
mps have criticized the department of
health
for in their words overseeing years of
decline in the nhs in england a report
by the public accounts committee says
nhs cancer and waiting times targets are
underperforming and 6.1 million people
are waiting for treatment
looking at some of the pictures making
the morning papers for you and the
guardian has this picture of a mum on
the
far left there she is
looking at her newborn baby in odessa in
ukraine the times has this shot of a
street
in the same city here we go
times
there we go uh looking like the beaches
of normandy
to block russian tanks and the telegraph
shows us women in northern india
celebrating the first day of holi which
is the hindu spring festival of colours
it looks like they're having a great
time don't they
maybe not the late i don't know why
she's got that thing on her head at the
back
somebody will tell me
i probably offended somebody i'm sorry
in advance now the government has
abandoned its animals abroad bill which
would have brought some of the toughest
laws in the world on the import of
gruesome animal souvenirs such as lion
heads what is that about joining us now
is the environmental journalist safari
operator and the director of the
campaign group bloodlines ian mickler hi
ian thanks for joining us on the
programme your reaction to the news
well first of all good morning um yes
very disappointing but um given the
background to
how this came about
there's a lot of mismatched logic and
reasoning here so
i i guess it's hardly surprising but
hopefully um
you know we can turn this around and it
can be resubmitted in months to come
i can't begin to comprehend why they
would not just um sign this through um
animals are such majestic creatures and
are endangered aren't they
yes so i i think the first the first
point to make is that um for me and and
many other uh scientists
conservationists um people who live and
work in africa in these spaces
we don't believe that trophy hunting is
an effective
uh or efficient conservation tool so i
think that's the you know very important
point to put forward but secondly if you
look at the
the background and i think that'll lead
to why
we're in this position so the hunting
bands were gazetted against a background
that still permitted hunting of sorts in
the uk so there's a contradiction there
in some ways um
and then we had
the the
the the sentience laws and the welfare
legislation proposed so having a
turnaround will complete a bad face also
brings those laws and and those attempts
into contradiction
you know another mismatched logic here
is that we have an acceptance as you say
that uh wildlife is in steep decline uh
alarmingly so for many species
many of them are regarded as endangered
but then
is the current government saying hang on
they're going back on their logic and
it's still okay to kill them for sport
um and and of course the interesting
part is that this seems to be a reversal
against overwhelming majorities in the
uk
um and especially the conservative party
who are against um trophy hunting and
importing these trophies so i think
okay in the end it looks like a very
powerful minority lobby representing the
vested interests
has again influenced the political
system and and and this is no doubt that
you know the powerful hunting bodies as
well as party donors and other elites
okay are you quietly hopeful though that
it may be revisited
well i think it must be revisited
because
uh increasingly we're seeing that uh you
know the science
is showing that actually it's not an
effective way
to
conserve
our
threatened and endangered species um you
know we continue to have tens of
thousands of these animals killed over
every decade yet the statistics show
that these animals continue to be in
decline
um and so i think what we have here is
we have hunters
using what what i refer to as mismatched
reasoning so they try to justify a sport
and a pastime
using a conservation argument and it's
mismatched and this is taking place when
we're having this ethical reckoning
really
and we're asking this question is is in
what many scientists are calling the
beginning of the sixth mass extinction
are we still going to justify
the fact that we can go out and kill
many of these endangered animals for fun
and i think increasingly the hunting
fraternity will be on the back foot
because it just doesn't add up it's it's
simply
it's not acceptable it's not working
and actually at the end of the day it's
unethical and immoral
it certainly is thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning thank you hopefully the
government will change their minds soon
thank you
that makes my blood boil i mean why why
i don't i just don't get it um let's
find out what's happening in ukraine
this morning should we we've seen a
missile strike
in the early hours of this morning let's
have a quick look
[Music]
goodness me um we can't
say what building was hit there but the
i'm guessing it's a russian uh missile
and uh they continue to bombard um kiev
which is almost completely surrounded
now by uh russian troops and artillery
we're approaching the three-week mark of
the war in ukraine and each morning
ukrainians in the eastern city of
kharkiv are waking up to sights like
this
this used to be a quiet
neighborhood in the city center
and now it is
completely in ruins
destroyed because of the russian
bombardments
well the shelling has been
indiscriminate
and the effect has been drastic for
those offering palliative care to
children in the city the russian strikes
have destroyed vital healthcare
facilities and hospices and those still
working in the city a warning of
difficulties getting aid to the children
that need it including dr andre penkov
who is joining us now hello to doctor uh
thank you for joining us a
pediatrician i should say um
the challenge is um that
normal everyday people are facing in
ukraine tragic when those people are
then ill i can't even begin to
comprehend tell me some of the
challenges that people are facing
okay
thank you so much for invitation thank
you so much
uh oh
[Music]
british people for help
your prime minister
he's uh
doing a lot for us now
to help with this war
uh and
um
me and my colleague elena are now in
kharkov
and i
can tell you that uh situation
absolutely horrible
russian army destroyed
more than 600
buildings including schools
hospitals
hospices and
the the big challenge is a lack of
medications lack of medical services
because
many people uh left our city but still
hundred thousand uh in here in in our
city and uh
all day i on the call i
counseling the
parents and
[Music]
sick children ill children and the big
problem is
they cannot
reach the medical
service they cannot go to
doctors
because
there are a lot of areas
without a medical service
concerning the palliative care it's a
disaster disaster um
in 2015 uh
elena and i visited loveboro and
the famous
children
hospice the first children's hospital in
the world
now rainbow
if you know
which was
leaded by dr sabir jazal i would to tell
him big thanks and
uh say hello to sabir to armor
they invited us and we tried to build uh
the same system in ukraine we try to
help vulnerable children children with
severe
medical conditions but now the help for
these children absolutely impossible
impossible
it's about specialists it's about
medications it's about services it's
about equipment
uh
i would say it's uh it's disaster for
these people people many families
divided and
women and children left our city a lot
of old
people
their grandmothers fathers they stay
here without medical help
nobody can uh
yeah
i completely understand and i'm so sorry
we are out of time but do keep in touch
with us and we'd like to check in with
you again and see how the situation is
developing thank you so much for taking
the time to join us on the program
breaking news from ukraine in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
foreign